hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and today we're going to do the rare
thing here on mindscape and actually
talk about something that i'm supposed
to be an expert in
you know and we talked to neda
engelhardt a little while ago about
black hole information and i've actually
written papers about black hole
information
but it's never been the central concern
of my research it's always been sort of
a side light for me
one thing that i have been very very
concerned about is large-scale cosmology
the expansion and acceleration of the
universe
so today we're extremely happy to have
as our guest adam reese
who is one of the discoverers of the
acceleration of the universe
and who has been noting that there is
another cosmological
anomaly known as the hubble tension that
calls into question the beautiful fit
that we have
in our cosmological models that we've
been very proud of over the last 20
years
since the acceleration of the universe
was discovered as adam alludes to
in the podcast he and i were graduate
students together
in the astronomy department at harvard
at the same time adam was a floor below
me
in perkins hall my office mate was brian
schmidt who went on to
lead the high redshift supernova team uh
so
adam and brian were two people who
shared the nobel prize with saul
promoter for discovering the
acceleration of the universe so i like
to think
that uh even though i had nothing to do
with the actual research that i at least
put them in the mindset of thinking
about the acceleration of the universe i
was
i was interested in it at the time i
wrote a uh review article with bill
press and ed turner
about the possibility that there could
be a cosmological constant
though to be perfectly honest i was
absolutely not saying
uh in the early 1990s that there
probably is a cosmodrome constant or
dark energy or the acceleration of the
universe
you would have won money from me if you
had tried to bet me at even money
and you had taken the side that there
was a non-zero cosmological constant i
was skeptical and in my review article
i gave you all the reasons to be
skeptical i said here's why it'd be
really really weird if this were
actually true
adam and brian uh and saul and their
their two big and very very talented
teams
showed that there was so that was a huge
surprise and you know as
we talk about in this podcast it was the
kind of thing even though it was a huge
surprise in 1998 when they discovered
the acceleration of the universe
we instantly had a good explanation for
the surprise right like the idea of a
cosmological constant had been proposed
by einstein
in 1917 and this is why in 1992 we could
write a review article about it even
though we were skeptical that it was
there we knew what it would be like
if it were there and when the high
redshift supernova team in the supernova
cosmology project
got evidence that the universe was
accelerating we could instantly go ah
here's the explanation let's think about
this and so in some sense the
observations were confirmed by
theory as they say nowadays adam is
pushing hard on a different kind
of discrepancy between expectation and
reality
there's two different ways of thinking
about uh of thinking about
measuring the expansion rate of the
universe so not the cosmos constant but
the hubble constant the current rate
at which the universe is expanding you
can just do it directly
like hubble did looking out in the sky
and measuring the recession velocity of
galaxies
or you can infer it from bigger picture
measurements of cosmology including the
cosmic microwave background
turns out as adam has been emphasizing
for a couple years now
these two methods give different answers
and
closer inspection has not brought them
into closer alignment it has driven them
apart it has
made the discrepancy even larger the
problem now is that this is
not an experimental result that is
confirmed by theory we don't have any
real good obvious theoretical ways of
dealing with this
so adam is also a great communicator
we'll do a very fun job of
building up slowly the basics of
cosmology to what this
discrepancy really is about and some of
the ways you could possibly
try to cure it we don't know if it's
real we don't know what the cure would
be if it were
real so this is very much an ongoing
research problem
in cosmology let me remind you if you
don't already know that we have a
patreon for supporters of the mindscape
podcast you can go to patreon.com
sean m carroll and what you get for
throwing a few bucks my way
is uh you get monthly ask me anything
episodes so we're trying to make the ask
me anything episodes publicly available
to listen to
but if you actually want to ask
questions you have to support on patreon
that's where the question asking happens
and the other thing is you get ad-free
versions of the podcast i don't think
the ads are very objectionable even if
they're there
but if you like your podcast experience
to be completely pristine and
uninterrupted
you can get that at the patreon site but
again as i always like to say
if you don't want to support that's
completely fine it's completely optional
we love you anyway thanks for listening
to the mindscape podcast that's the most
important thing so with that
let's go
[Music]
adam reese welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for having me
so it's a big universe out there i know
that uh you've been charged with
figuring it how big it is how fast it's
expanding things like that
i think i'm hoping that over the course
of this podcast we can sort of go from
the very basics to some
pretty deep stuff but let's let's start
with the basics like how do you think
about modern cosmology what does a
person on the street need to know about
the universe on the larger scales
right well you know they should know
that the universe is expanding
um that it looks like we live in a
fairly ordinary place in the universe
and one of the most i think profound and
ambitious uh endeavors we take as humans
is to understand the universe to
uh make measurements of it and
understand how old it is uh
uh what its fate is what it's composed
of and
we do these things both observationally
and theoretically
and it's it's on the one hand we say
that it's smooth it looks more or less
the same everywhere but that's only on
very large scales right it's lumpy with
galaxies and stars on smaller scales
correct i mean it's just like looking at
the earth you know any particular spot
it might be a lake it might be a
mountain but
you know if you take a big enough chunk
then um you get a bunch of lakes a bunch
of mountains various things it starts to
average out
and so if we i mean why don't you just
again for the people who really
i don't know if i have any listeners who
fit into this category but for the
people who really uh
don't know if the universe is expanding
now it must have been smaller in the
past what do we know about that
yeah well um you know the evidence to us
that that is the case
is uh when we uh look out
we look back in time so we can literally
see those times when the universe was
more compact and we see it was hotter
as you expect when things uh are close
together they
they get hot and uh when they separate
they get cool
uh we also see things generally uh age
in the universe which tells us that uh
you know really was
younger in the past and uh it is older
now and of course
when we look at all the objects around
us we see their light has been stretched
or red shifted by the expansion of space
and so uh if those motions of the
objects around us were just random like
the like
you get with the doppler effect when
something is moving toward or away from
you it could
go either way the the light could get uh
blue shifted or red shifted but we see
pretty much
everything is red shifted which tells us
that uh it must be all of space that is
expanding
i i do even at this late date sometimes
get questions about are we sure the
universe is expanding
versus what you and i would call a tired
light kind of perspective like the light
just loses energy into the universe as
time goes
on do you have a favorite uh response to
those kinds of questions
um yeah you know one of my favorite uh
observational consequences
of expansion that wouldn't happen if you
just had tired light
uh is uh the fact that uh distant
objects not only
uh do they move away from us quickly but
uh the events that occur
far away are stretched or dilated
uh due to the expansion of space so
that's another consequence that wouldn't
happen with tired light and indeed when
we look at for example
uh a certain kind of a supernova
explosion a type 1a supernova
we know what the evolution of that
explosion is very well it takes
you know 20 days to go from explosion to
maximum
and we see that period elongated by
exactly the amount you would expect
because of the expansion of space in
some cases up to double or even triple
uh the normal time intervals so we have
some very good evidence that the
universe is expanding
and actually that's a good example of i
think a paradigm is going to come back
in
again and again in the conversation
which is that you have an idea like the
universe is expanding and you don't just
test it in one way
right like these are systems that fit
together in many many different ways and
the
whole paradigm of the expanding universe
according to general relativity
uh could have failed in many many
different ways and we've looked at it
and so far it's on the right track
yes that is absolutely true so it seems
the other thing that i think that people
uh don't appreciate maybe as much as as
i would like them to is
it's kind of easy relatively speaking
to measure the redshift to a galaxy or
something like that whereas
it's really hard to measure the distance
and this is basically your stock and
trade now right measuring distances to
far away objects
yeah and you know it's very
non-intuitive i mean you know if you
look at a
a faraway car uh and i ask you
you know how far away is that car you
know you have a good sense of how big a
car
is yeah and so the fact that it's an
itty-bitty car you say uh you know looks
like uh
you know 100 yards away if i ask you you
know how fast is it traveling
and you would have a very hard time
judging that especially if it's coming
directly
at you um and so you know what is easy
for us here on earth and what is hard is
exactly sort of inverted i would say
and when we look out uh in space and
primarily that's because
the objects we see in space unlike cars
are
not familiar to us we don't get to walk
right up to one
and sort of eyeball and say oh so that's
how big a car is uh
you know in our case it might be a
galaxy it might be an exploding star
but you know we don't get to walk up to
these things and figure out
you know intrinsically their properties
how luminous or how big
and so we always struggle a little bit
with figuring out when we see
an itty-bitty one or i think one far
away just how far away that is
right because cars are either more or
less the same size or at least we think
we know how big they are whereas the
universe is a
is full of messy non-standard things
like stars like you just said you know
stars could be big stars could be small
so
what do we do about this i guess you
know the idea is if we have some
standard object
that we know how big it is intrinsically
or we know how bright it is
then by measuring how big it appears or
how bright it appears we can
figure out exposed facto how far away it
is
right that's right um and so that is our
challenge um of course
we have tools uh one of our favorite
tools really goes back to the greeks
uh and is the idea of parallax uh
as the earth goes around the sun our
perspective
on uh relatively nearby objects changes
with respect to more distant objects
same experience we all have if you you
know take a walk and look at
how nearby trees move a lot and far away
tree move very little
um and uh that is just basic
trigonometry
uh all you have to do is know the
diameter of the earth's orbit which you
know
and measure those small angle and you
can figure out exactly how far away
the nearest stars are and
is that generally what you do or that
that's just the first step on the ladder
right that is
that is where we start in many cases uh
we measure how far away the nearest
stars are
um unfortunately it turns out stars are
very far away
and so the angle the parallax angle that
angle through with the star move
often becomes very very small it becomes
you know uh a milli arc second uh for
instance
uh might be a typical value uh for the
kind of stars we're interested
in and so therefore we can really only
measure
uh the stars sort of nearby to us uh how
far away they are
and from there we sort of have to
bootstrap you know we have to uh
find uh if we're lucky a very luminous
version of one of those stars
uh measure its distance infer its
luminosity and then
if we're lucky we can use a powerful
telescope like hubble
and see one of those exact same kind of
stars in another galaxy
perhaps a galaxy that hosted a supernova
explosion
and so that allows us to calibrate the
luminosity of the supernova which
those we can see much further away so i
guess what you're
sort of hinting at but maybe it's worth
laying on the table is the idea
of this distance ladder that we we can
see the parallax for the stars nearby
but for the galaxies that we care about
receding from us
and you know of cosmological interest
there's essentially zero chance we will
ever measure the parallax there so we
have to bootstrap our way up
that's right that's right and so this
concept of a distance ladder which we've
been around a long time in cosmology
uh is really it's not based on physics
it's really just
geometry uh and this you know simple
idea
that if two things are co-located uh
then uh if you understand what one of
those objects is if you can use that to
gauge the distance
then you essentially calibrate the other
object that it's co-located with
it does though you know it begins to
make us think that this is a tricky
business right there's a lot of steps
along the way and there's going to be
little errors at each step so
uh you got to work very very hard to
make sure that this is you know
every every floor of the very tall
building
is firmly established that's correct
that's correct and so
you know one of the trickiest parts is
to make sure
that uh when you build a distance ladder
that the
the nearby version and the distant
version
of the same object you're looking at
whether that be a star or a supernova
that those are really the same objects
yeah and of course
as you put together a number of steps
any error you make in one step will
propagate
up the measurement chain and so that's
why
um you know in the old days when people
built distance ladders
it was a rickety distance ladder i would
say with you know
8 10 12 rungs and now we've gotten it
down to just about
three rungs and so that really
simplifies in quite a bit
uh another uh significant improvement is
we've been able to
make those measurements in a more
homogeneous way we use
now the same telescope to observe for
example
the nearby stars and those distant stars
in other galaxies
and so the problem of calibrating your
telescope sort of drops out
in the analysis yeah i wouldn't even
thought that would be a problem but yes
now that you mentioned it it sounds like
it sounds like a big one so
yeah okay i mean you've mentioned
supernovae they've been very important
to your career why don't you tell us a
little bit about how
the supernova can be used as a distance
object i remember
you know when i was in graduate school
the idea that we would even look for
supernovae rather than just being lucky
enough to see one was kind of heretical
right um well you know we're very
fortunate uh that uh there are not many
macroscopic objects
in the universe that are coolly standard
that are more or less the theme
uh but there is a limiting mass uh for
uh a certain kind of star a very compact
star when its material is
in a degenerate state known as the
chandrasekhar limit
named after of course chandrasekhar who
showed
these back in the 1930s that uh there
was limit about 1.4 times the mass of
our sun
and if a star reaches that limit and
surpasses it we believe you get a
runaway thermonuclear explosion you have
the
conditions for fusion uh all over the
star
and so this is kind of a standard bomb
so we believe that there are
these stars that exist below the tundra
they car limit
but that they uh live in binary systems
that there are
other stars next to them and uh sometime
over the life
of those cool stars mass may transfer
from one star to the other that could
happen because one star swells up
it could happen because they merge but
either way
that white dwarf uh we call star uh
crosses that chandrasekhar limit and
explodes and that gives us
a very uniform explosion and well when
we see these objects and recognize
them far away we can uh infer
their distance from their brightness
as fun as it is to have an hour or two
of interesting conversation about big
ideas
sometimes you just need to have 6 hours
or 12 hours or even 24 hours of
information being beamed into your brain
if that's the case i recommend you check
out the great
courses plus it's a streaming service
that offers you
access to a whole bunch of different
topics taught by the great courses so
you have some of the world's best
professors
teaching everything from astronomy to
history to psychology to cooking
and it's a very convenient mechanism
because with the great courses plus
app you can watch on your mobile device
you can watch on your laptop you can
even watch on your tv
recently we had the bad news of the
passing of eddie van halen the legendary
guitarist
well maybe you're going to be the next
legendary guitarist you could check out
the course
playing guitar like a pro lead solo and
group performance at the great courses
plus
taught by colin mcallister if you have a
little extra time on your hands
learning a musical instrument might be a
nice thing to do
so continue your journey as a lifelong
learner by signing up for the great
courses plus and mindscape listeners
have a limited time deal a free month of
access to the entire library and to
start your free month you must sign up
today using the special url
the great courses plus dot com slash
mindscape that's the great courses
p-l-u-s
dot com slash mindscape start learning
today
right and i think then mostly what i
want to do here is talk about
uh the hubble tension and the modern
stuff but
while we have you here i can't help but
ask a little bit about the famous
discovery 1998 of the accelerating
universe
so this was something that was done with
supernovae playing a big part
you were uh part of the team won the
nobel prize etc like
tell us number one what you did as a
scientist but maybe also
what was going through your head when
you first realized oh my goodness the
universe is accelerating this is not
something that uh i
expected anyway well actually uh uh to
be honest you were part of it i'll
mention
the second but uh so our uh our
team had been measuring nearby type one
a supernova engaging how fast the
universe was expanding
by measuring their distances in
redshifts uh what was new by the mid
1990s it became possible for the first
time with
bigger telescope and bigger detectors to
find
distance supernovae sort of on demand
that is
you uh search a wide swath of the sky
and
return to that uh point um
you know a month later so digitally
subtract images
uh and find uh a new exploding star
but these were very faint ones very
distant ones that were telling us how
fast the universe was expanding in the
past
maybe five to seven billion years ago uh
and by comparing the past expansion rate
to the present expansion rate
uh we could infer how much the expansion
was slowing down
at least that's what we thought that
would be slowing down i thought
you know the attractive gravity of all
the stuff in the universe would slow it
down
so um in 1998 i was a a postdoctoral
fellow
working on the hindi supernova team and
was
uh pulling together this data and i
wrote a simple
computer program to tell me okay what is
the the mass
of the universe that would cause this
much deceleration
uh not yet realizing that that's not
what was going on and so
my little computer program i wrote
reported back that the best fitting mass
to the
universe was a negative yes and of
course
you know there's no such thing but you
know now i like to say computers don't
know physics
um you know they just know whatever
equation you give them and so
after a few days of course realizing
this is really unphysical there's no
such thing as
negative mass uh i pulled up a a review
article that you wrote in uh 1997 was it
uh i think it was 92 which year was it
92 i think 92 i'm sorry 1992. um
a review article uh that you wrote
talking about the cosmological constant
you know it's long and tortured history
of this sort of um
uh repulsive gravity term uh that could
uh cause the universe to expand faster
and accelerate and uh so you know i paud
through that
found the relevant equations and uh
refit the data
uh using those and uh lo and behold you
know the data was arguing very strongly
uh for the need for something like this
clock module constant in lieu of
negative matter and i always think
that's kind of a funny way to think of
it because
uh you know in in the simple equation
they would almost look the same except
one of them
is uh potentially physical and the other
is not
so the the best fit was a positive
amount of matter but this repulsive uh
force due to the cosmological constant
correct about about 30 percent in this
uh in manner and about 70 percent in the
form of this
cosmodrome conquered or dark energy and
but again it was a surprise right like
did you have to sort of uh
we've all written computer programs that
have gotten the wrong answer so yeah
there must
so you know i certainly spent a while
trying to
figure out what was going on you know
feeling oh obviously i've made some kind
of mistake but you know it's quite
frustrating when you look for a mistake
and you don't find it
and you know this is the value of being
on a team with smart people
at some point you realize you know i'm
just never going to find this bug
but you know somebody else will not make
the same mistake or have the same bug so
you know i pass the data to brian
schmidt um who you know quite well yep
was your office mate and uh the leader
of our team and he
uh refit the data writing his own
program and he got the same answer and
then at some point
we started uh getting enough confidence
in this uh
and uh you know the rest is history but
the
result came from measuring the supernova
like you said you know
roughly speaking you expect them to be
uniform because the chandrasekhar limit
is uniform
that's not exactly true but you can
hopefully correct for that but
how worried were you that there was just
something weird going on with supernovae
not not with the cosmos constant
right um you know we studied that pretty
carefully so my
thesis had been about measuring
distances to supernovae
and correcting for annoying effects like
dust in uh galaxies
that might block the light of supernovae
and fool you into thinking
they're further away than they really
are so um
we had used uh that those techniques and
and uh related techniques to
account for things like that what we
worried about was whether
supernovae born when the universe was
younger were just different than the
ones born today
yeah but fortunately even nearby
we have analogs for what i would call
old and young
supernovae we have uh galaxies that are
essentially what we call old galaxies
they only have old stars they're sort of
like senior citizens homes
and then we have young galaxies uh which
primarily have
young stars and so uh those are spirals
and ellipticals
and nearby we have type 1a supernovae in
both those counter galaxies
and so we were able to demonstrate and
convince ourselves that our techniques
uh gave distances to those galaxies that
were agnostic about
what kind of galaxy and how old they
were and so
it finally came down to sort of saying
to ourselves i mean if the supernova
doesn't know how old
it is in its galaxy how does it know how
old it is in the universe
yeah and so you know at some point you
know you you do the best you can and
eventually you know you go ahead and you
publish
those results and of course you know
what was really convincing to not just
us but the community was that other
techniques
completely unrelated to supernovae uh
reached the same conclusion within about
i think two or three years
yes which makes this a perfect segue so
you know by the way congratulations
accelerating universe that's pretty
awesome but you did not uh
rest on your laurels you've kept going
and it makes sense at this point to
bring in a whole other part of the story
because like you said it was
verified by independent methods and one
of the big methods was the cosmic
microwave background so why don't you
tell us that story a little bit
sure so you know the cosmic microwave
background provides us
a completely different i would say
measurement chain but also
way of looking at the universe we can
see
the radiation the heat left over from
the big bang and there are
structures in that heat left over
that allow us to calibrate in a
completely different way
the state of the universe and so
uh i told you earlier that we had
measured about 30 percent of the
universe in the form of this matter
and about 70 percent in the form of this
dark energy
uh reaching this sort of hundred percent
if you will
um and the cosmic microwave background
basically came along and
said yeah we see that hundred percent
too um you know they have
different sensitivities so they couldn't
and initially break it into
which part was matter and which part was
energy but astronomers had four
decades measured the amount of matter in
the universe to be that 30 percent
and so really the only options were that
uh there was the 30 percent
and this you know 70 percent existed in
in this cosmological constant or it
didn't
uh and so the fact that the classic
microwave background came in
and measured and very precisely i should
say
measured the sum total to be you know
the hundred percent within
a couple percent uh really uh cinched it
at that point
okay but we've you know we've done our
due diligence in explaining that the
universe is expanding and stuff like
that uh to the people who are not
experts so let's roll up our sleeves and
get in the details a little bit
how how in the world does measuring
light left over from the big bang tell
me anything at all
about what the matter or energy content
is today
right well you know you might think
about it like this it tells us very much
about what the state of the universe was
how much
matter and energy and how fast it was
expanding shortly after the big bang
which is
an awfully long time ago you know more
than 13 billion years ago
and what's so great about physics is if
you understand physics well
and you measure you know the state of an
object maybe a moving object through
your room
uh if you understand physics well enough
you ought to be able to predict
the state of that object at any time in
the future um you know i'm thinking in a
particularly classical way but you know
that is generally true and so
uh the the observations of the cosmic
microwave background told us to stable
the universe shortly after the big bang
and then with our brand new shiny
cosmological model
we could use that model to then
propagate forward or extrapolate to the
present time
how fast the universe ought to be
expanding it's it's really i would say
prediction uh it's not a measurement the
the measurement
occurs shortly after the big bang and
then the model is used to make a
prediction of how fast it should be
expanding today
and the specific thing that you're uh
measuring is not just the amount of
radiation
in the microwave background but the
temperature of it and how that is
different from point to point in the sky
when you look at it right
that's right that's correct so you're
measuring the you're measuring the
the spectrum of fluctuations and so you
see this kind of
modeled looking map and uh uh physicists
then uh take what we call fourier
transform to measure
uh how much of that spottiness on
different scales exists
and because this is kind of a a ringing
oscillating
fluid shortly after the big bang by
comparing the
the actual measurements to models that
predict what those measurements should
look like
we essentially set the what we call the
free parameters
of the cosmological model and then use
the that calibration of the model to
propagate the story forward to the
problem
so this is it seems to be if i pretend
to be an outsider for a second
this also seems to be a bit of a um
a ladder of some sort in other words
when we try to measure
parameters using the cosmic microwave
background it's not like
the cmb is holding up a sign saying here
is the density of matter or anything
like that there's
these temperature fluctuations and we
have a very very
theoretically uh motivated set of
predictions for what those fluctuations
should be
depending on the temperature depending
on the parameters and then we fit
right and it's sort of a back and forth
that's correct and you know the way the
game is normally played is you know you
start out and say you know what is the
fewest number of parameters or the
simplest physics
i can use to explain the data that we
have
uh and so that's what allows you to fit
this model uh
you know at early times uh one thing
very important for people to understand
is the universe looked
very different shortly after the big
bang it was mostly matter
and neutrinos and radiation the universe
then looked
very different at late times it's mostly
dark energy
and a fair bit of matter neutrinos
become unimportant
and so you fit with the simplest physics
you can this model
and then you know cross fingers hope
that you know that is the complete story
and then use that model uh to make a
prediction about the present
uh of course you know one of the
challenges in this is 95
of the model as we know it today is dark
it's
you know dark matter and dark energy and
we don't really know
uh much about the physics of dark matter
and dark energy and so
what we do is we take the most vanilla
virgins of those you know in the case of
dark matter we say
okay it looks like a particle for
various reasons uh
we don't know much about the
interactions of that particle we don't
know how stable that particle is
um we don't know if it decays uh but
let's assume
none of those things uh and in the case
of dark energy while we don't
understand it we say let's say that's
static and fixed just like the
cosmological constant
and then uh we use that most vanilla
version to make this prediction
and uh just to jump right to the punch
line uh what we see
and it's pretty remarkable right now is
that we do not see agreement
uh to the precision of the measurements
right i mean that's the that's the most
recent wrinkle that we want to dive into
but
it's it's a tough line to walk down
because
i want to care about and and really um
think carefully about the most recent
tension but
also there's a lot of agreement and you
know it's
it's it's something where if you're not
in the game i think a lot of people say
well
look you've invoked this dark matter
stuff this dark energy stuff i'm not
surprised it doesn't fit at all like
maybe you just don't know what you're
talking about
right um yeah no it's certainly a a
give-and-take sort of process i mean you
know we there are ways
uh or there are other measurements i
think that confirm and corroborate
each of these different pieces i mean
you know in the case of dark matter
you know we see uh the rotation curves
of galaxies
are flat which is uh the way we say that
you know galaxies are really spinning
way too fast if there weren't
lots of dark matter in them and we see
uh galaxies whizzing around clusters of
galaxies much too fast
for those galaxies to uh stay connected
to those clusters we're not for dark
matter in those clusters
and then uh in terms of dark energy we
see uh
we have other ways of gauging distances
in the nearby universe that have nothing
to do with supernovae
that also show the universe to be
accelerating and so
um you know this is a a multi-piece
puzzle and the
the cosmological model we have today has
sort of survived
all of various measurements uh it's you
know the best thing that we have now but
it doesn't necessarily mean it's
complete
yeah and uh it but it is it's
it is uh i guess the thing i want to
emphasize is
and if you agree with me here um we
would
love to be able to say the model was
wrong right like that that's the thing
that makes us happy is i think that a
lot of people
have the idea that we we some have a
vested interest
in the success of dark matter and dark
energy being simple and and whatever
like we
have bought stock in it but as
scientists you know we're most excited
when it's completely wrong
well that's right because you know i
would say you know it depends a little
bit about your model i mean if we
thought we understood absolutely
everything about the model we might be a
little horrified if the model didn't
work somewhere
but when we have a model that has such
large swaths of of
ignorance really then seeing the model
not work somewhere
you know is offers the best opportunity
or really clue we could potentially have
to the physics that we're missing in the
model and so i agree with you
in the current context with you know so
much dark matter dark energy
if something didn't fit that would be
fantastic news
here at mindscape we look at the big
picture ideas the lasting images that
will hopefully still be interesting
thousands of years from now
but the latest news is also important we
live in a world that is changing very
rapidly and it's important to keep up
especially in an area like technology
where change happens very very fast
for three years and nearly 800 episodes
the tech meme
ride home podcast has been one of
silicon valley's
favorite ways to get tech news the tech
meme ride home is a daily podcast
it's only 15 or 20 minutes long and
every day by 5 pm eastern
you get all the latest tech news and
it's not just something that's
aggregated together by some
automatic scraping system you get the
context you get the top stories the top
posts
and the conversations around those
stories as well as
behind the scenes analysis it gives you
that extra little bit of insight you get
beyond the headlines the folks at tech
meme are online
all day reading everything so they can
boil it down
and catch you up so if you're interested
in keeping on top of tech whether
because you're in silicon valley
yourself or you just want to understand
this changing technological world around
us
search your podcast app now for ride
home and subscribe to the tech
meme ride home podcast
and good so let's let's get into the the
modern tension but first i just wanted
to sort of
summarize what we mean when we say
the model so we have the hot big bang we
have these parameters why don't you put
into your own words
sure um you know we have the hot big
bang um and then you know we have
different constituents in the universe
we have uh
uh particles uh called neutrinos that
have you know very little mass
uh a lot of them whizz around they act a
lot like
light or energy but as i said they have
a little mass so they don't quite travel
at the speed of light and
physicists have certain descriptions of
how to um
explain those we have of course
radiation you know we have
this dark matter uh we have dark energy
and as
uh the universe expands uh these
different components will
dilute in uh different ways uh what else
do we have you know we have the basic
laws of physics
as we understand them we have a theory
of gravity general relativity that is
sort of
embedded in all this uh because you know
we always have to question
whether we have the right story there as
well um
so you know we stay the cosmological
model but we really mean
uh a certain uh certain constituents in
certain amounts
and certain physics and we have
confidence that the dark matter is not
just
ordinary matter we haven't seen yet
that's correct
where does that come from yeah so uh i
guess that has to do with um
uh depending on what the density of
matter
is in the early universe uh it tells us
um through a process called nuclear
synthesis when the universe was very hot
and dense
how much fusion will go on and how much
of certain primordial
elements you will produce for example
helium is a great
example and so um if you if all
of the matter in the universe was normal
or what we call baryonic matter you
wouldn't produce the right amount of
helium
um and so that's a that's a critical uh
peaceful story is to have
some matter that is not ordinary in fact
most of it uh
is in what we call non-baryonic or kind
of um
you know uh some form that you wouldn't
recognize from your high school
chemistry class you know in the periodic
table of elements or the
the list of basic particles um and so
that's very important uh
back 20 to 30 years ago people used to
argue whether those were
uh particles or whether those were giant
bricks
uh or you know macroscopic objects and
uh
well i would say there's still some
debate about that for the most part
we've ruled out that they're macroscopic
objects because we don't see
enough other effects from those
macroscopic objects something called
micro lensing when you know one of those
bricks or microscopic objects would pass
between us and a star
it would produce a a kind of change in
the brightness of that star
and we don't see enough of that to uh
find that much of it is in that form
uh i remember when the ligo results
first came out we discovered that there
was gravitational
waves coming from binary stars were you
one of the people who uh
wondered out loud whether or not big
black holes could be the dark matter
yes um yeah and i was i mean uh really
mark kaminkowski's group
really spearheaded that uh i think i
contributed a lunchroom conversation to
that paper
however i think it's really intriguing
today you know ligo is finding these uh
super massive
these very large black holes that are
you know can be like 60 times the math
of the sun
uh and what we know it's very very rare
for stars that large to form
or particularly for the remnants of bars
that large to exist
so there's some kind of process that may
be producing
uh bigger heavier things from smaller
things bombing
on together and so you know one could
imagine that that's been a recent
process of you know
massive stars coming from black holes
that are maybe one two
four solar masses kind of glomming onto
each other uh
in in the centers of clusters of of
stars uh or it could be you know the
kind of snowball effect from
you know little things starting off
shortly after the big bang that were
black holes and then glomming on
over a much longer period of time and so
uh you know that's an active area of
research it's
it's uh something i think it's very
interesting do you still think it's an
open possibility that the dark matter is
black holes of some form that are left
over from uh the early universe or do
you think
i haven't followed this story as closely
as i would like but i've seen a fair bit
of back and forth there are other
constraints that make it difficult for
it to be a lot of the dark matter
it could be i think a small amount of
the dark matter and i think the jury's
still out at that okay okay good all
right so the final sort of preparatory
question is when we talk about the
standard cosmological model as
you know you described it there's
expansion there's dark matter there's
ordinary matter there's dark energy
um what about inflation this is an idea
you know in the very early universe
super rel super rapid expansion uh
certainly very popular idea
in your mind do you count that as part
of the standard picture or as a more
speculative add-on
right you know it um i guess and now um
i'll have to remind myself a little bit
uh after the conversation you know
i don't usually think or deal with the
universe much uh
around the time of inflation however you
know it does set initial conditions for
the standard model and some of the
parameters
uh in the standard model uh and you know
that affect the causing microwave
background
do come from inflation uh i think
and my understanding uh usually is
inflation is a generic enough phenomenon
that you know
they don't necessarily prove that
inflation incurred
at this point um but you know it was
sort of part of the setting of the stage
for what comes next in the observations
of the causing migrate background
okay but then i so i take it that you
would say that you know if we find out
that inflation was not right
uh we would still say the general hot
big bang model could be completely
correct in fact
i think the general hot big bang model
is more or less just correct right like
that's not still
up in the air to debate that's correct
okay
so nevertheless good so with all that
groundwork uh laid
there seems to be an issue like you
you've kept on measuring
the the hubble constant the expansion
rate of the universe you know you should
sort of start out measuring it and then
you showed that it was
it was a terrible mistake actually to
keep making measurements one should
certainly stop when everything looks
good there are laurels you should rest
on them why don't you take this advice
come on really was a blonder so
and we also have this wonderful picture
where there's multiple sources of data
and
inference from whether it's supernovae
or galaxies or the microwave background
or whatever
and what we would hope is that we sort
of with improved precision
narrow in on the right answer and it
seems that with improved precision
we're finding that it doesn't quite fit
as nicely as we would like
that's right so uh you know i would say
in
broader brush strokes you know the early
2000s was a period of great harmony in
cosmology where
various techniques at better precision
than
before but all good as precision as we
had now
we're pointing to the same you know
gross order picture this hot big bang
model
with large dollop of dark energy and a
smaller dollop of dark matter um and you
know this was all glorious and you know
we were all patting ourselves on the
back
um and then as i said we made the
mistake of continuing to
improve the precision of all the
measurement and then
we started to see these these tensions
really i would say between
uh the uh the early universe's
measurement and predictions coming from
the model to
what the state of the universe should be
today versus uh more direct measurement
of that present state of the universe
and these have come up in
a couple ways one a little better known
than the other one is
measuring how fast the universe is
expanding the hubble constant
and the other is measuring how clumpy
the universe is today
uh and both of these seem to be in some
level of tension or difference
so good let's let's dig into both of
them uh one at a time so the
the hubble tension as it's been called
uh
roughly speaking two different ways of
measuring the expansion rate they
disagree
right um but you know as i said the key
thing is
one is a a measurement and then the use
of
of a physics model to you know make a
prediction
and the other is a more direct version
of that measurement and so
when you you start at the early universe
and you
uh make those measurements and you use
the model you predict
the universe should be expanding at
about 67
plus or minus 0.5 kilometers per second
per megaparsec
um and when you make those measurements
uh locally while there are various
methods
and i would say they get a full range of
about 70 to 75
all of those methods uh are coming out
higher
than the early universe then uh you know
i would say the average is sort of
around
73 plus or minus one and a half
so we're looking at somewhere between
four to six
uh error bars or standard deviations of
separation now
between uh the the average of those uh
late universe measurements the the
present measurement and
uh those early universe predictions uh
so much so
that uh you know i really can't point to
any one
thing that could be an error that could
explain this difference because there
are so
many independent uh methods that are
used at both ends
so let's just bring it down even a
little bit more what is your favorite
way of directly measuring the expansion
rate
today i mean my favorite way is must be
the one i work on because uh
you know you have choices in this world
and so those are the ones i've chosen to
work on and so
you know the type 1a supernovae i think
uh are without a doubt
the best way we have measuring
long-range differences
and uh these pulsating stars called
sepia variables uh they've been around
the longest uh you know going back more
than a hundred years when
henrietta leavitt um measured them
in the uh nearby neighbor the large
magellanic cloud
they are also about the most luminous
star
you could see in a distant galaxy and
they have a wonderful property
which is that they blink they pulsate
and the
period with which they pulsate which can
be from days to
months has a very tight correspondence
to their luminosity it's because these
are super giant stars
and as you might imagine something far
larger
and more massive a picture of this very
large star
who orbit probably goes out to you know
neptune or something
and imagine how long it would take to uh
have a star like that compress and
expand like an accordion
and the bigger it is the longer it's
going to take by the process of gravity
and so the very big ones are the more
luminous ones and their
period tells us that the fact that it
takes a very long time
for them to undergo one of those
pulsations whereas the
smaller and less luminous ones might
only take a day or so and so
uh we look at a nearby galaxy that
hosted a type 1a supernova with the
hubble space telescope
and we could pick out individual
luminous stars and
we monitor that galaxy maybe a dozen
times over the course of a couple of
months
and we identify these cepheid stars
by their changing brightness they might
double their brightness over the course
of a couple of months
and uh we're able to pick them out and
uh compare them to their nearby brethren
many of which
we can now measure parallax to directly
and so it forms a pretty simple
measurement chain
parallax to the cepheid variables in the
milky way galaxy
observe those with the hubble space
telescope observe their
their brethren in nearby galaxies that
hosted type 1a supernovae
and then observed those type 18
supernovae even further into the
expanding universe
cool so that's the three-step ladder
that you say that we're now
able to do so henrietta levitt was stuck
just sort of picking out cepheids in the
large magellanic cloud and presuming
they were more or less the same distance
away
but now we can basically use parallax to
measure the distance to some cepheids
directly is that right
that's right um you know henrietta
levitt made this very important
uh realization that uh because all the
cephe we're looking at were in one
location far away from us but
in one location that she noticed the
ones that were more luminous
had the longer periods and so uh this
allowed her to
recognize that uh they didn't just look
brighter they actually were brighter
they were more luminous because they
were co-located with
other scepians they were feiner and had
shorter periods and then we go from
cepheids in other galaxies
to supernova because uh there are some
supernovae that are in the same galaxies
as the cepheids i mean how many
how many type 1a supernovae have we
observed with
cepheids in their galaxies so so you
know a type 1a supernova is is a pretty
rare phenomenon there's only you know
one in a galaxy like ours every 100
years
and so most galaxies we know of we have
not seen a type 1a supernova
in it there's only you know really some
handfuls that we have
nearby however most galaxies do
have these cepheid variables so we do
the process uh
sort of in reverse you know first you
find the galaxy with a supernova then
you go back and look for sepia variables
in these galaxies
with the hubble space telescope and
particularly with its
newer instrumentation which has only
been available in the last
10 years or so we can do this out to a
distance of about 40 or 50 megaparsecs
and in that
volume there's a good type 1a supernova
about once a year
maybe once every two years um and so
we are just this year completing i think
a complete sample of what i would call
all of the type 18 super adobe
in the last 30 or 40 years uh
that you can calibrate with cepheid
variables and so that'll be about 38
objects total
um and the precision of each of the
those type one a supernova is about six
percent in distance and so
if you have 38 objects that you can
measure individually to six percent in
distance
that gets you close to about one percent
overall
and you know that is sort of the holy
grail of measurements
of the hubble constant is to get to a
one percent precise measurement our
our most recent effort of a few years
ago was more like two percent
um and you know this may sound like
small differences but you know when
you're trying to understand the cause of
the pension
improving the measurements is is really
one of the better ways we have
i mean again when i was a graduate
student we didn't know whether the
hubble constant was 50 or 100
and so now we're arguing whether it's 72
or 73 so
that's much more interesting because i
would i would say you know when when you
and i were graduate students and people
were measuring whether it was 50 or 100
they were measuring whether it was 50 or
100 in the same nearby universe often
with some of the same data
and so you knew you know both things
couldn't be true what's so interesting
right now
is you know we're talking about a
difference between what we see
in the nearby universe or what we infer
from early times
and it is possible that both those
measurements are true
and that we're learning something isn't
quite right about the model i mean we
don't know that for sure
uh that's why we continue to improve the
measurements but that's why it's a
fundamentally different and potentially
much more exciting possibility than that
you know than uh you know the the less
filling taste grade argument
well it was it was hilarious with the 50
versus 100 is that nobody thought it was
70 or 75 right even though
that was the average and that's what it
more or less turned out to be
uh let me before before we keep moving
on you know you mentioned the hubble
space telescope
and number one how amazing is it that
that
guy is still going running strong and
number two
is the next generation is the james webb
space telescope going to make your job
much easier
yeah um well first of all it is amazing
that that hubble's still going and you
know it's really
a testament to nasa and the space
program the astronauts because
being able to go back up and service it
if uh the astronauts had
not been able to do that a number of
times we would not have the telescope
now for sure
they also brought it you know very much
up to date um and so one of the
wonderful things when you have a complex
piece of machinery like the hubble space
telescope is
things break uh particularly early on
things have sort of infant mortality
and so if you can service it for a while
if you could spend a while you know
replacing all the parts that break
broke easily then what you get by the
end is something that's quite robust
quite spurty yeah and so we have not
only a you know pretty up-to-date
telescope because it was serviced 10
years ago
with modern instruments but we also have
one that's quite robust because
we've replaced all the bad parts um and
so that's what makes it quite incredible
today
um the net telescope the james webb
space telescope will allow us to
sort of further into the path it's not
particularly optimized i would say for
the projects that i do um
hubble really is better for that but uh
i think that there will be other kinds
of measurements you can make with the
james webb space telescope
that shed light on this issue uh
sometimes in
expected ways sometimes probably in
unexpected ways
is uh hubble gonna be retired is it
gonna keep going even when we get james
w webb up there
yeah well you know there's no like
retirement ceremony where you know we
hoist
jersey into the raptors and uh
you know put it in the hall of fame and
you know we're to keep using it
um until you know so many parts are
broken and that's as i said not the case
now that it isn't
you know particularly useful or cost too
much to continue to operate
um at one point you know with orbit is
thinking um and so uh it begins to touch
the atmosphere which causes uh its orbit
to sink uh
even more and at some point it will
re-enter
or uh napa will have to uh you know
attach something to it and drive it into
the ocean because it's too large to
allow it to just fall
and that's the price you pay for having
it be serviceable that it's in a
near-earth orbit and it will decay
that's right absolutely and the jwst is
not going to be serviceable it's going
to be away the hell out there
yeah it's going to be way the hell out
there you know much further away than
the moon is uh at a point a little
second lagrange point and uh that of
course makes it even more critical that
uh it works very well from the beginning
because uh
astronauts are not gonna be able to go
out there okay very good thank you for
the technological update here but so we
have this nice
relatively clean three-step um hubble
distance ladder
let me i mean let me just ask what are
the prospects for a
lurking systematic error like cepheid
variables in the milky way are all weird
and that's the very first step on the
ladder
yes so that's a great question so i gave
a kind of simplified version of the
ladder but
you know we have now i would say three
pretty equally good ways
to calibrate the luminosity of cepheids
one is actually the parallax
measurements in the milky way uh we also
see the cepheid variables in the large
menthol in a cloud
and there are other geometric techniques
that allow us to measure the distances
to the
large the listen to the large magellanic
cloud other kinds of
systems called detached eclipsing binary
systems
uh that calibrate the loom uh cepheids
to about 1.2 percent
um there are also uh masers in uh
keplerian motion
around a supermassive black hole in a
galaxy called
ngp 4258 and we calibrate the luminosity
of the cepheids in there so we have
about
three completely unrelated methods for
making those measurements
uh and they all give a very consistent
result that is consistently in tension
with the
early universe uh and so that's why i
say it's high we're you know we're
having a harder and harder time getting
out of this problem
by blaming systematic errors you know we
continue to
you know look carefully for them
diligently um
you know it's funny we talked about that
uh that discovery 20 years ago about the
acceleration of the universe
uh ironically i would actually say this
is an easier measurement than that was
because
you know 20 years ago we had to do our
best to figure out
uh and uh conclude that distant type 1a
supernova when the universe was very
young
are the thing as we see today yeah in
this case the measurements i'm talking
about are all done
essentially today they're all done
nearby at low redshifts and so
many things are easier about this
measurement and so it's it's been harder
to understand
uh you know some kind of systematic
error that could be causing this
so we have a bunch of different
independent fairly robust
seeming ways of measuring the local
nearby
expansion rate and we get numbers like
72 or 73.
and then we have the cosmic microwave
background that implies
something like 67. uh is it this is a
difficult question i know
is it is it possible to give an
intuitive understanding of how
you determine the expansion rate of the
universe today
because you're not you're not trying to
discover the expansion of the universe
when the microwave background was formed
you're using data from the microwave
background
to infer the expansion rate today so how
is that supposed to work
um how is it that you uh that you infer
an expansion rate today from the early
universe
yeah um you know i guess i would i mean
i i think the easiest picture for
anybody to sort of have is imagine that
we are measuring essentially the
expansion rate of the universe
shortly after the big bang at that time
and then we have a
kinematic model that's essentially what
the the
the model in the form of a well-known
equation called the friedman equation
allows us to propagate that forward in
time
to the present time and so you know it
is you know it's a prediction
however there are uh we get along the
way
uh for example you know uh in that
calculation we get to check along the
way
our distance supernovae or uh other
tools called baryon acoustic
oscillations
are they showing us an expansion history
that is consistent with that uh fit to
the free bond equation along the way and
the answer is yes
um and so that gives us a lot of
confidence in this process
however there's i would say at this
point in my mind one of the bigger flies
in the ointment
is do we have the right description of
the universe not just today but
before uh the classic microwave
background
light is emitted um that is do we have
the right model of the universe shortly
after the big bang when
it would have been dominated by uh
neutrinos
radiation dark matter and it would have
been so
hot and dense that you know it makes you
think about
interaction of dark matter or
interactions of dark matter with dark
energy or with neutrinos
in a way that we wouldn't recognize
today because now the universe is very
diluted
um because of the expansion and so you
know it's it's a very different universe
shortly after the big bang
are there any kind of other in hormone
geneties are we missing a particle i
mean i'm a
i'm an astronomer and i don't usually
think about particles
but you know when the universe is very
young it's all particle hybrid
it's all you know a giant accelerator
and uh you know if you have
another neutrino for instance it changes
the proportions of
energy in the early universe and changes
our understanding of how fast it would
expand
at early times and it changes
essentially the calibration
of the cosmic microwave background just
like we calibrate the luminosity of a
supernova that's our standard candle
they have a standard ruler really which
is the
physical size of a fluctuation
in the plasma of the early universe uh
which can travel
from uh or expand from the time of the
big bang
to uh the moment when the universe
becomes
transparent when the the radiation can
escape and travel to us
um and if we do not understand the
uh expansion at those early times
for example if there's another neutrino
in the universe
it causes more energy to be in what we
call relativistic like particles
it would uh increase the expansion at
early times
and thin out the universe faster causing
it to become transparent
earlier which changes the size of this
sound horizon
this you know the distance that this
sound wave can travel
up until that time and so you know
that's something people have been taking
a look at recently is
you know are there ways to change the
cosmological model you know a piece
a wrinkle something were missing either
in the physics or the components
of the model but at early times that
could bring these two things into accord
and uh for example one possibility
people
looked at is what's called early dark
energy uh another
episode of dark energy so if you're
counting at home this would be the third
episode of dark energy right there is
the one that we think gave rise to
inflation there's the one that
accelerates the universe today
this would be a a a field driven uh
dark energy that would uh exist shortly
before their big bang and would
push the universe apart faster uh so
those are the the kinds of things people
look at
so okay good so let me just let me just
sort of see if i can absorb all this
so we have the direct measurement of the
expansion rate
today gets the 72 or 73 we have this
fitting to the big old model and using
the cosmic microwave background that
seems to
imply what we that we should measure
the hubble constant today to be 67 so
those disagree
and my impression both from having read
things
i'll i'll confess despite having uh uh
history as a theoretical
cosmologist i've not followed uh the
latest wrinkles in
in this game so i'm relying on you here
but
my impression both from reading things
and from listening to you right now
is that the ways that we could tweak the
models
to bring these discrepancies into
alignment once again
are focusing more on the early universe
than on the current universe like you
might think well
the cmb predicts something we disagree
with it today therefore let's change
today
but people seem to be saying that that's
harder to do than to like add some new
things to the early universe
right you know it's not so much that
it's harder to do theoretically it's
that it's harder to do
from um from the data it's really
raining us in at this point i mean
if if you would told me about the
problem you know 20 years ago
shortly after discovering uh dark energy
right our first statement would have
been oh so it's not a cosmological
confidence
um it it has an equation of state uh
sort of you know the ratio of its uh
pressure to its energy density which is
uh more negative than minus one which
20 years ago would have bothered you
very much because very much
i think you probably still would still
would bother me very unlikely
uh but you know observationally would
have said that now with additional
observations of high ridge of supernovae
baryon acoustic oscillations
uh and other techniques we've seen oh no
the equation is actually very close to
minus one within you know five percent
or so
and so therefore the late time behavior
of the universe is much like the
standard model
uh and so that's why as i said we turn
our attention to
another place you know the model really
comes in in two critical places in this
story
one is before the radiation from the big
bang uh you know comes out to us
and the other is in the late universe
and so if the late universe is more off
the hook
then we look at the early universe now
it's not easy in the early universe
either because
the uh the spectrum of the cosmic
microwave background has been measured
so exquisitely
that uh if you try to monkey around you
know you throw in a uh
you know a neutrino willy-nilly um you
know it will produce
other achievements in the spectrum that
are not allowed and so
we're reigned in i would say less than
in the late universe
in terms of creativity space but um
still quite rained in
um and so you know it's it's hard it is
i would say hard both from theoretical
standpoint
uh and also from a systematic error
standpoint um
you know i might say at this point that
you know there's not right now one sort
of
uh silver bullet that uh comes in and
explains the whole thing but there are
interesting theoretical ideas that get
close but
are you know what you might call
fine-tuned a little bit um there
are suggestions people have made of
systematic errors that might knock out
you know one observation but not a other
observation so then you need
you know multiple maybe a conspiracy of
systematic errors
and so you know that's why that's why
it's the hubble tension
right well maybe before before getting
deeper into the ideas maybe just a
personal
uh you know a bayesian prior or or
credence that you can offer us
do what do you think the chances are
that this discrepancy will at the end
just be a systematic error or some
mistake in the observations versus being
new physics or something exciting
yeah you know it's it's really hard i i
i've learned
to not try to guess
my favorite example from teaching uh you
know astro 101 is you know the
the parable of uh vulcan um
or maybe to uranus and and uh uh mercury
um you know uranus was not traveling as
uh it ought to have been um and
uh astronomers speculated that there was
another planet that was tugging on it
which turned out to be neptune and in
fact
those calculations allowed them to look
exactly you know where it was and so
you know in that case it was actually
you know a new
object to see uh you know in the case of
mercury mercury was processing in its
orbit which was recognized you know a
couple of decades later
and uh uh people tried the same trick ah
i've seen this
problem before there must be another
planet between you know mercury and the
sun
which they named the vulcan because it
would have been so darn hot there
um and uh you know they looked and
looked for it for decades and never
found it and they
turned out they had the wrong physics
you know the wrong theory of gravity
so you know you might call neptune the
systematic error
and you might call you know uh general
relativity that came from this the
you know the new physics and you know
sometimes you could look at the exact
same uh
you know discrepancy and it's one or the
other and you know your intuition fails
you so
you know i don't know uh you know to me
this is one of the most interesting
things going on in the universe right
now
i think it is something interesting and
you know i don't consider a simple
systematic error as interesting
um so i think it's you know it is
something
that will tell us something about the
universe around us but you know whether
that's
local about the astrophysics of objects
in the universe
or whether it's um you know something
more
about uh you know the actual physics
like gravity i don't know
okay so you're weaseling out i get it no
problem you have you have the right to
do that but
well let me ask this you mentioned that
there were these um proposals out there
hard-working young theoretical
cosmologists making up crazy ideas for
the early universe
is there uh you know my particular style
for doing cosmology
is less let's propose a particular new
particle or whatever and more
well what's the general kind of thing we
need i mean is there
is there a thing that you can say like
if we just made the universe expand a
little faster because there is more
energy density at early times that
solves all of our problems or is it more
subtle than that
um yeah you know
um at this point you know we're
tightening
i would say the sort of noose at both
ends of
space and time and we're looking for
well looked like we've got those story
um you know sometimes that happens
you know you you know oil seeing the you
know resonance of carbon was a just
those story because it had to
uh at some point um you know it could be
you know dramatically different physics
and you know we just don't have the
right picture right um it could be you
know nature's so cruel to us
you know it's going to three different
systematic errors that you know that all
go in the same direction
um i mean you laugh but it could be
that's a real possibility
you know i mean you'd be crazy not to
say that i mean you know these are
measurements these are observations life
is hard
um you know that those systematic errors
could be either in the late
time or early time universe or both of
them you know i know
smart people who will say oh it's just
like
you know in the past was it 50 or 100 it
was in between and so they'll say yeah
oh is it 67 or 73 well it's 70 it's in
between
um you know it that's not very
satisfying because
you know for the most part you know uh
saying that there's a tension between 67
and 73
you don't escape that by saying well the
answer's in the middle because
you know both ends don't like that very
much now you have two tensions
sorry now you have two tensions instead
of just one right your attention so you
know
you i mean it might seem clever to sort
of uh conclude that
but you know we're not really interested
believe it or not in the value of the
hubble concert we're interested in why
we don't get a match between these two
ways of looking at things that is what
potentially tells us
more about the universe just you know if
aliens arrived and just told us the
answer
you know whatever they said it was you
know that wouldn't necessarily explain
what is going on
right um so it's not this is not a quest
to measure a number this is the quest
to do an end-to-end test of the universe
and understand why it's failing
you did tease us a little bit uh at the
very beginning with mentioning that it's
not just the hubble measurement that's
in tension but there is this problem
with the lumpiness of the universe as
well
that's right so there's another
parameter which is uh often goes by the
catchy name of sigma eight
and it measures the clumpiness of matter
and so likewise
in the early universe because you know
we know the state of the universe
shortly after the big bang and then we
know how it dilutes due to expansion
we should be able to predict how clumpy
it should be today and then we have
techniques which are also hard but are
powerful of measuring how clumpy it is
uh either by measuring uh this
phenomenon called weak lending where we
measure how
clumps of matter distort the shapes the
apparent shapes of galaxies
or by measuring the motions of galaxies
uh
extra motion due to not the expansion of
space but
matter the clumpiness of matter and uh
those
two at this point disagree with each
other
at i guess the most recent numbers i've
seen is sort of three sigma from each of
those the lensing method
and the peculiar velocity method and in
the same direction that you know the
the late universe measurements are
in a different direction in terms of
size uh
to the sigma eight number as multiple
early universe measurements
so you know clever people are trying to
think about can you think of one
physical story that would explain both
of these tensions i think that's turned
out to be equally difficult but
you know the the reductionist in all of
us sort of wants to think
if there is a physics answer it would
explain both it would be simpler yeah i
mean this is an
entirely unfair question but this is the
benefit of being the questioner rather
than question e
is it possible that there's like a big
thing that we're missing not like just
there's another particle or something is
there something that we're just
misconstruing about the nature of the
universe that would help explain this
kind of thing
you know i go back to gravity in a way
because you know if somebody was looking
at the procession of mercury and you
know somebody whispered in your ear
it's new physics right you would go well
it must be you know small perturbation
and newton's gravity right i mean we
pretty much get everything right there's
just one
one little detail left and that is
completely wrong as you know
you know general relativity is nothing
like newtonian physics it's not a
wrinkle
um and so the the moral of the story is
it can be very difficult to predict when
we
we can explain an enormous number of
phenomenon
in the universe with the standard model
and there's only uh
as i said i present a couple of these
tensions but you know are these the
threads in the sweater that you know you
pull on them and the whole sweater
unravels
or you know are they little threads that
you pull them and you go oh those were
just some loose threads on the sweater
and you know i it's it's very difficult
to guess i mean you might have a better
um you know more intuition about that
than i do
well i'll tell you my intuition which is
that uh as someone who's tried to do
this
changing gravity in such a way that it
fits
the solar system and the binary pulsar
and gravitational waves and all that
but is different for cosmology is just
not only
hard because we've tried it and it's
been difficult but also
not at all what you'd expect from the
philosophy of effective field theory
and something like that like in the weak
regime where the whole universe is there
we should be on firm ground but but it's
in the nature of large conceptual
mistakes that you don't know you're
making them while you're going on so i'm
in favor of keeping open mind that's
true and not only that you know when you
start talking about things like dark
energy
and uh the cosmological constant or even
inflation and you talk about what is
natural
in our current understanding of gravity
uh you know you
you run into real trouble you know in
terms of uh
understanding you know the the size and
scale of for example the cosmological
constant so
it's one thing to say well you know i
just have these few tensions these loose
threads in a sweater and it's another
thing to also recognize
and i expect some enormous um
uh you know new understanding to come
along because i also have this other
enormous lurking problem which is you
know the ignorance about
you know dark energy why is lambda as we
call it so small
um and so you know all of these things
are kind of in the backdrop so i you
know i don't know whether
you know the problem with these loose
threads on this sweater or the fact that
we don't know how to make a sweater at
all
right and i think that the the thing
that um is important is not only that
the vacuum energy that we need to invoke
to fit everything is small
but also the coincidence problem right
that it's approximately the same
order of magnitude it is the same order
of magnitude as the matter density which
leads people to wonder about the
anthropic principle in the multiverse
but
also might lead us to say well we're we
just don't have a good idea what's going
on right now and
i think even as i say that the words
escape my mouth i feel the need to say
but you know what that idea fits a huge
amount of data so don't just
dismiss it too lightly right that's
right you know um
but you know in in in any field and you
know i think this is a good field
you know you what the measure of how
rich it is is you know you ask for its
top 10 list of problems
and you know you hope that they're not
all tiny uh if you know it's an
interesting field and this is that kind
of field where there are these you know
enormous
problems but then there are these sort
of little clues and so
you know the question is do they connect
i mean it's not anything goes as you say
i mean there are a great number of
things that we know quite well and i've
mentioned quite well and you know work
quite well with the theory
but then you know like the analogy of
newtonian gravity to general relativity
you know
is this just a special case of a deeper
theory um you know that's what we don't
know and so you know clever people
smarter than me
for sure um look at all of these clues
and uh you know try to put it all
together
um you know one interesting question you
know people often ask me you know
how close are we to a theoretical
breakthrough and
you know when you think about einstein
and general relativity you know
what were the clues you know uh you know
it was a year or two before
you know did you know we were almost
there you know is there is there
markers of progress along the way before
giant theoretical breakthroughs come
through
i mean i don't think so yeah that that's
a tough one of course you can't predict
the next theoretical breakthrough so
that's that is a
one to to wisely safely pass on when
people ask you that question so
instead i mean let me wind things up by
asking you a question you're much more
um
equipped to answer what are the things
we should be looking at next like be the
observational
cosmologist here like what are the what
are the tactics we can use to actually
learn more about the phenomenon here
right so there are going to be a great
number of new
and highly precise measures of the late
time
expansion history of the universe coming
from all kinds of new facilities
that will tell us if indeed there is a
component of this story coming from
some misunderstanding there or whether
we can rule that out completely
at the same time there will be new
observations of the cosmic microwave
background in greater detail
and other uh scales of fluctuation in
polarization
that can look for extra features in the
cosmic microwave background
that would be predicted if there is some
other uh
component of the universe at early times
um and so that's important there will be
more measurements of the expansion rate
of the universe uh there's uh
this facility ligo that measures
gravitational waves
it's going to be measuring uh objects
that we call standard
sirens they're like standard candles
only uh
in gravitational waves instead of light
that can be used to independently
measure the hubble constant at late
times
look for any sources of systematic error
um and so you know all these will come
together
and i think um you know over the next
decade i'd be surprised
i mean most of the time when you're
looking at a problem if it's been around
you know for 50 or 100 years it's going
to be around a lot longer but
you know the hubble tensions maybe only
been around five years so
you know maybe the next 10 years will be
uh you know uh
we'll really solve it i would hope so
yeah you know i actually uh was one of
the ones who coined the term
standard sirens uh that was one of my
contributions to cosmology i don't make
major breakthroughs myself but i'm
friends with a lot of people who do so i
i help to you know change the the way
that we talk about them
um but also maybe maybe one last food
for thought thing
is the difference in
sort of style of what's going on right
now versus what went on 20 years ago
with the acceleration of the universe i
mean with that
it was a big important huge surprising
discovery
but it was pretty quick like you made it
and people said oh yeah okay this is
what's happening
and in part because we had a theoretical
explanation ready to hand
right and this one is much more creeping
up on us the discrepancy has been there
for a while and it's growing and
if it's real we're still not quite sure
what to do with it yeah
you know it is an interesting contrast
and i could almost argue either side of
that you know 20 years ago we said oh
you know the universe is accelerating
could that really be and you know right
away people said yes because there's a
cosmodrome constant aha
we have a ready explanation and yet as
you know um
that explanation comes with a huge
number of problems as well
you know what is that really an
explanation or is that kind of a
placeholder i mean the
you know there's math and and some
rudimentary physics but you know not a
really detailed understanding and so
um you know uh it you know it it's hard
to say
whether uh you know maybe we don't have
that sort of
idea now but you know as i said i'm not
sure that that idea that we had 20 years
ago was the final story there either
yep you know i'd like to think that if
this podcast has any function it's to uh
be listened to by young people who are
still in their formative years and
they'll be inspired to solve some of
these difficult problems we keep talking
about so maybe
maybe someone in the audience someone
mindscape listener will go solve the
hubble
tension problem that would be a good
outcome yes
all right adam reese thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast all right
thank you sean
[Music]
do
[Music]
you